the universe appears to be a smoothly
running mechanism that is always in
motion
moons orbit their planets
planets orbit their stars and stars on
their turn orbit the center of their
galaxy
this coordinated motion is predefined by
the fundamental laws of nature
but is there a special point among all
this motion
does the universe have a center
before we get started we have to decide
what it is we're looking for
what could be called the center of the
universe
the central point of the solar system is
the common center of the masses of all
the objects it is comprised of which in
essence is almost at the center of the
sun
there is a similar central point for the
milky way and for the virgo supercluster
that our galaxy is part of
can we carry on in the same manner and
eventually pinpoint the pivot of the
entire universe
if we look at the large-scale structure
of the universe we will notice the
following
stars form galaxies of three basic types
spiral elliptical and irregular
it is quite easy to find the central
point in the first two whereas it is
considerably harder to do so in those of
the latter type
moving on galaxies group together to
form clusters and superclusters these in
their turn form galactic filaments
these filaments distributed all over the
universe are interspersed with
mysterious areas of almost total
emptiness
voids voids are areas so enormous that
they would easily accommodate thousands
of galaxies
the large-scale structure of the
universe is made up of these two global
components
by the way we have a special video about
voids so feel free to check it out if
you haven't seen it yet
now seen on the scale of hundreds of
megapass sex the universe turns out to
be quite homogeneous
its makeup resembles a sponge it goes
without saying that there are massive
mata flows and points of matter
attraction like the dark flow and the
great attractor but their influence is
not global enough to make them suitable
candidates for the center of the
universe
to date no object has been discovered in
the visible universe that would qualify
to be the common center of gravity
in fact if it did exist out there its
influence would be too pervasive not to
be noticed
it is actually according to the
fundamental cosmological principle that
the universe is homogeneous and
isotropic
this means that the universe would look
the same irrespective of either the
whereabouts of the observer or the
direction we choose to look in
the cosmological principle was
formulated based on copious observations
of remote areas of the universe and is
applicable on the scale of hundreds of
millions of light years
if the potential observer on the earth
inquiringly gazed at the universe all
round it would appear to be a sphere
with a radius measuring 46 billion light
years its center being in the solar
system
this is the actual distance to the
remotest visible object although it took
its slight approximately 13.8 billion
years to reach our earth
the sphere is known as the observable
universe or meta galaxy
however it would be erroneous to
consider our location the center of the
universe
this is pretty much like claiming you're
in the middle of the planet when in
reality you are simply at the center of
a circle drawn by the horizon on the
planet's surface all around you
the meta galaxy has equal chances of
being either a small part of the
universe or constituting it in its
entirety
it is quite impossible at this point to
find this out for certain
let's assume there is no pivot we can
pinpoint in the universe today perhaps
we should try a different attack then
according to contemporary scientific
views
the universe was born approximately 13.8
billion years ago as a result of the
event generally referred to as the big
bang
before that time and space as we know
them were virtually non-existent
it appears logical to suppose therefore
that if there was a bang it had to have
a center
in other words the starting point of all
let's sneak a peek at the past
the consequences of the early stages of
the universe's evolution still widely
manifest themselves
the ones that stand out are the
cosmological expansion of space and the
cosmic microwave background radiation or
the cmb radiation would observing these
phenomena bear fruit
would it be possible to locate the
central point and did it exist at all
the cosmological expansion of the
universe is an isotropic and homogeneous
expansion of space from point to point
it may seem that it would be enough to
just measure the velocity and direction
of this expansion and then rewind time
as it were thus tracing the motion back
to its origins at the center
but this isn't quite as simple as that
straightforward calculations would show
the center of the universe's expansion
to be in really close proximity to the
solar system
on more precise observation it will turn
out the disposed center of the big bang
lands right on top of the observer
however the tricky part is that even if
we were to travel to any other point in
space like a few light years away it is
this point that would appear to be the
center from which space objects recede
strangely the result will be the same in
any point in the universe
here is an example i've already told you
about in our video about the universe's
expansion imagine a balloon filled with
air with a few dots marked on it they're
motionless relative to each other but if
we pump more air into the balloon
the distances between the dots will grow
at the same time obviously none of them
may be considered the center of the
balloon's expansion
the dots recede from each other at a
steady pace and the rate of this process
depends on the distances between them
the notion of the event horizon is
inferred from the concept of the
expansion of the universe since the rate
at which objects recede depends on the
distances between them
at a certain point the observable object
is bound to move away from us at a rate
exceeding the speed of light
according to the special theory of
relativity this implies that any
interaction with that object will be
impossible
objects beyond the event horizon are as
well as gone for the observer we will
never find out what will happen to them
next
in this respect the universe is a sphere
with the consciously assigned center at
the point of observation
and its limit is marked by the event
horizon
different values for its radius may be
produced in different models of the
universe but it definitely measures over
14 billion light years
however
any other point in the universe will
have its own event horizon that is why
it would not be fair to favor the
position of the observer and see it as
the center of the universe
it is hardly necessary to point out that
the number of such-like centers would be
infinite
so it looks like there is no way we can
find the center of the universe with the
help of its cosmological expansion
how about relic radiation then
relic radiation or the cmb radiation is
high frequency background radiation that
permeates the universe in all directions
its temperature which is approximately
2.7 kelvin slowly drops on account of
the universe's expansion
the cmb radiation is an important source
of information as it originated in the
early stages of the universe's evolution
as a result of massive recombination of
protons
relic radiation used to be considered
homogeneous and isotropic for a long
time this means that a detector at any
point in the universe and aimed in any
direction should show the same density
of the radiation
however in recent years quite a few
areas were found not to conform to this
rule
it is the case with voids for example
the cmb temperatures in these dark areas
are minuscule portions of a kelvin lower
than the cmb temperature in the rest of
space
there are other areas in the universe
where the cosmic microwave background is
anything but isotropic for instance
photons may be swallowed up by a cloud
of hot gas or may end up in a powerful
gravitational field
besides as the sun along with all of its
planets goes round the center of the
milky way
this motion causes the cmb spectre to
shift depending on the direction of
measurement
to put it simply
the earth moves away from the cmb
radiation flow aimed at its back as it
were while meeting the cmb radiation
flow aimed at its front
this produces the doppler effect that
causes the observed radiation to shift
to the red or the blue band
respectively still all cases of
manifested anisotropy of the cmb are
secondary
they are the consequences of the
interaction between the cmb radiation
and heavy objects
or alternatively voids
according to contemporary science there
may well have been primary deviations
that occurred in the earliest stages of
the universe's expansion
if they were to be discovered they would
make a great source of valuable
information about events taking place in
the first seconds after the birth of
space and time as we more or less know
them
unfortunately primary anisotropy of the
cmb radiation hasn't been discovered
experimentally yet
to sum up on balance no point in space
should be considered its center
the expansion of the universe occurs
simultaneously across its entire
infinity and no special area can be
realistically and accurately singled out
on the ultimate global level
there isn't a single mass center that
could play the role of the pivot with
all other space rotating on it
however this mysterious place may well
exist but too far away from us
the dimensions of the universe still
haven't been gauged with a satisfying
degree of accuracy
since even the latest cutting-edge
measuring equipment produced by the
human civilization isn't able to reach
beyond the event horizon
the part of space that can be observed
by us may well be a minuscule droplet in
comparison with the rich ocean of the
universe
and it is hardly feasible that we will
ever be able to appreciate it in its
entirety
[Music]
you